So I don't want to goEpisode.
I didn't want to go
But
It's 70% of the reason I didn't want to go
is cuz I was going to drive and I said
specifically did if it was going to happen
the only way it would be if I was right
Somehow I'm sorry
For you I will
I'm doing it okay I'm actively preparing to
leave okay okay as long as I'm moving in the
direction you want
I'm already in the door you wait you riding
with me too
When you stop saying that she won't talk it
into it please and I was just playing with
you
Oh well actually
But they don't listen
Give me some holiday music excuse me good
sir I need I needYeah you don't need them
cuz I'm blasted.
I needWhat do I need. I need to Jingle Bell
Rock Mix.
They don't got to Thanksgiving guyRight
ain't no Thanksgiving song what's the
Thanksgiving song.
Name of Thanksgiving song
I'm trying to get some
Music set up
I don't want to get all the way to
Kirbyville and still not happy music
Hey google?
Make sure I went Home Depot
Baby baby baby
Throwback 80s music
Is this more likeIt's more like whatever
growing up.
So I just had that firstTime.
Are you got the laptop
How do you love me
From deep in my soul
I'll let me get that right there
ThereThat would be.
And then they might stickI'll do that little
sign they do and they come.
Beautiful transition
I just wanted to let you knowI did.
Mama tell him how about that shit up earlier
today I said I say I say I say 70%, you
remember you was there that's why that's
what that's why I just said
But Mama made it seem like I had to drive
like we had no plans like if I had to drive
I was going to drive
Okay
So let me go back upstairs it's not my plan
I'm just the law for the ride I'm barely
alive
Hello cuz they're about like it's called
Lucas and light so he's starting
Again
I ain't even think about that alreadyDid
that speak a lot of cheese.
And I can have it on the back of my neighbor
on the back of the street I'm about to wake
up the whole neighborhood since I got to be
up this early
Where's my foodI've lost my keys.
Help me find them
And make sure you got everything moving into
her3/8.
So
I'm trying
Who got nothing
Going 70
Let me see something it is critical
Emergen